i've been requested to do some more
implicit uh differentiation or
differentiation of implicit functions by
uh
i believe his name is akash uh so i will
do some more and these are actually the
problems that he sent to me and they
looked good so those are the ones i'll
do
so the first problem he gave me and i'll
do it in green
it says see y
to the third power
minus
x
y
squared
plus
cosine
x
y
is equal to 2.
so like all
differentiation of implicit functions
and of course in these examples i'm
going to except for the last one i'm
going to find the derivative of y with
respect to x so in all of these i want
to figure out what d y
d x
is equal to
well to do that just like in the
previous video we just take the
derivative with respect to x of both
sides of this equation so we we do the
different the derivative operator i
guess we could call it so we're going to
take it on this side
d dx
i'm going to
take the derivative of everything and
then we take the derivative on the right
hand side the derivative of 2 which we
know hopefully by this point is 0. and
i'll do it a little bit quicker than the
last video but
anyway send me a note if you think i did
it too fast
so let's take the derivative of each of
these terms so the derivative with
respect to x of y
cubed
well it's the derivative with respect to
y we're just doing the chain rule so
it's 3
y
that's a y not a g 3 y
squared
so the derivative of this function with
respect to y times the derivative of y
with respect to x
d y
d x that's just the chain rule
and then we have minus the derivative of
this with respect to x well this is a
little interesting because here we have
x times y squared which we're arguing is
maybe a function of what's an implicit
function of x so how do we do that well
we'll do let me put the subtraction sign
outside
and then let's do the derivative inside
and i'll do it inside some brackets
so let's do the product rule here right
we have x times y squared so let's the
product rule says you know the it's the
derivative of the first function times
the second function
plus
the derivative of the second function
times the first function so the
derivative of the first function with
respect to x right remember what we're
taking the derivative with respect to
well the derivative of x is just 1
right
1 times
y
squared
plus
the derivative of the second function
what's the derivative of the second
function
well it's going to be 2y
dydx and that just comes from the chain
rule
right
the derivative with respect to y times
the derivative of y with respect to x
this is the chain rule
so that's the derivative of y squared
and then we multiply that times the
first function which is x
times x
right hopefully that didn't confuse you
just took
derivative of x times y squared this is
the product rule plus the derivative of
y squared which was this
times x
okay now we're ready to move on
okay
plus now this is interesting this is
interesting
we have to take the derivative of cosine
of x y well once again we just do the
chain rule and maybe i'll actually break
it out into a couple of steps here just
so that you don't get completely
confused so what does the chain rule say
if we have you know f of g of x or
whatever whatever we essentially have to
take the derivative of the inside
function and multiply or well i guess
you could you could do it two ways you
could say we take the entire derivative
with respect to whatever this function
is
you know if g was equal to xy we could
say you know the derivative of cosine of
g with respect to g
and then we would multiply that times
the derivative of this
with respect to x if that confuses you
i'll i think it'll make more sense when
i actually do the example so this is
going to be
actually let me write it out like just
the way i said it because i think that
could maybe even clear up
some confusion over the chain rule or
maybe it will confuse you further
so what are we doing we're going to do
the derivative let me do this in a
different color
so
let's take the derivative of the outside
function with respect to x y
right so what is that what's the
derivative of cosine of x well it's or
what's the cosine let's say if it was g
is equal to xy
if g is equal to xy then that expression
there is cosine of g
right
so what's what's the derivative of this
with respect to g
sorry d g
well that's just minus sign of g right
so let me do that in a different color
so it's minus
sine
and g was just xy
xy
so that's the derivative of you can kind
of save the outside function and then we
go to the inside and we have to multiply
this times the derivative of this inside
function let me just write that like
this times
the derivative
with respect to x that's what we're
doing
of x y
and i'm going to leave it like that for
now because that's going to take a
little bit of space
and then that equals
the derivative of 2 with respect to x
well 2 never changes right it's a
constant so its derivative is 0.
so let's see if we can simplify
this a little bit we'll come back
actually let me just well we'll come
back to that let's just write this let's
see so right we have 3
g
i'm confusing myself with my bad
penmanship
3 y
all that talk of g got me confused
d y
dx
3y squared dydx
minus see y squared
minus i'm just distributing the minus
minus
well let's see xy minus 2 x y
2 x y
d
y
d x
minus sine of x y
minus sine
of x y
and then
this whole thing
times the derivative of x y with respect
to x well we could just do the product
rule here what's the derivative of x y
with respect to x well the derivative of
x is 1 so it's 1 times y
right derivative of the first times the
second function
plus the derivative of the second
function
with respect to x so the derivative
what's the derivative of y with respect
to x well it's just d y d x right d y
d x
times the first function that's just the
product rule review the product reveal
that was a little confusing
is equal to zero
and now we can
attempt to
simplify so let's see what i can do so
we have
y squared
d y d
x
minus
y
squared
minus 2 x y
d y
d x
now this one's interesting so let me
distribute the sine of x y
right this is just a 1. so it's
minus
y
sine
of
x y
minus y sine of x y
minus
x d y
d x sine of x y i'm just simplifying
this is just algebra
x y is equal to 0. now let's group all
of the terms that have a d y d x in them
and distribute out the dydx so this is
equal to
dy
dx
times this
3y squared
minus 2xy i'm just undistributing or i'm
dividing out the d y d x minus so let me
actually show you the terms so this has
a d y d x this has a d y d x and this is
just algebra this has a d y d x so let
me separate those out so it's 3 3y
squared
minus 2
xy
minus
x
sine
of
x
y
minus sine of x y well that's all the
ones with the d y d x on them
and then these terms and i'm just
skipping a couple of steps because this
is just algebra right now this the non
dy dx terms that term
and i guess there's only two of them
i'm just going to add to the other side
of the equation so i'm i'm just going to
bring them over to the other side
hopefully that step doesn't confuse you
this is just algebraic simplification at
this point
so that equals
i could have written minus y squared
minus y sine xy and then added them on
the other side but i'm about to run out
of space and time so i'm just going to
flip i'm just going to add both add
these to both sides of this equation so
that equals
y squared plus
y
sine
of x
y
right i think i've covered all of the
terms
and now since our goal is to find the
derivative of y with respect to x we can
divide both sides of this equation by
this term right here and our final
answer is the final answer let me do it
in a good color
d y
d x the derivative of y with respect to
x is equal to that
y squared plus y
sine
of x y
divided by this
y
squared minus 2 x y minus x
sine
of x y and there you have it that was a
good
implicit differentiation problem and if
you understood how to do that you
understand how to do implicit
differentiation and i hope i didn't make
any careless mistakes and it's a good
exercise for you to try to do it again
on your own see you soon